quantum supremacist that moment when a
quantum computer beats the best
supercomputers have solving some kind of
problem and it's a very exciting time
right now in quantum computing because
as of recording this video we're on the
brink of having quantum supremacy maybe
it's already happened
so I'm going to explain what quantum
super MSE is and why it's so exciting
so to explain quantum supremacy it's
worth me explaining how quantum
computers work as physicists we call
normal computers classical computers in
classical computers work with binary
there's loads of bits that can either be
in a state of 0 & 1 in a quantum
computer you have quantum bits qubits
which can be in the state 0 or 1 or they
can be in a special intermediate state
and that's called a superposition it's a
special phenomena in quantum physics
that quantum computers take advantage of
now when you measure a qubit the result
you get is based on a probability so if
you set the superposition state to be in
the middle you've got 50% chance of
getting a 0 and a 50% chance getting a 1
but you can tune that state so you can
make it so that you're more likely to
get a 0 than a 1 or the other way around
so that's the first phenomena of quantum
physics quantum computers take advantage
of the second one is called entanglement
and this is where you bring together
several qubits and you join them
together and now that whole thing has to
be treated as one object so if you take
two qubits and you join them together
now this object can be in the mixed
state of four states so 0 0 0 1 1 0 & 1
1 each time you add a new qubit you
double the number of states that this
thing can be in and that goes up
exponentially so if you want to search
through a whole load of different states
a classical computer has to search
through them one by one but in a quantum
computer you've got these special
quantum algorithms where you can enhance
the probability of the state that you
want and diminish the probability of it
giving you back the state that you don't
want so those two phenomena entanglement
and superposition what give quantum
computers their power so what kind of
quantum computers exist in the world
today so there are a whole bunch of
different companies trying to make a
quantum computer Google Intel IBM
Microsoft d-wave amongst others and to
complicate matters there's not just one
kind of quantum computer there's
actually a whole load of different
approaches I've broken them all down
here
an important thing to point out here a
universal quantum computers universal
quantum computing can theoretically
simulate any quantum system and so it's
the fundamental Computing Machinery of
the universe there's other proaches that
aren't universal like quantum annealing
and iron trap systems what they're
focused on solving certain niche
problems better than classical computers
by taking advantage of quantum physics
and they're a valid approach if those
kinds of problems are valuable they can
be used as a good stepping stone towards
a universal quantum computer because
Universal quantum computers are very
difficult to build and it's good to
learn stuff along the way I've also
included the number of qubits in these
quanta computer zazz of today now a
qubit number is just one measure of how
good a quantum computer is just as
important is how low the noises in the
qubits or how high-quality the qubits
are and also how well the qubits are
connected together
so let me describe a bit more about how
you do the experiment to prove quantum
Supremacy actually measuring when it's
happened is quite a difficult thing to
do so you take your best quantum
computer you take your best
supercomputer you need to give them a
problem to solve and then compare the
results and to begin with quantum
computers can't do anything better than
a supercomputer except for one thing and
that's be a quantum computer which might
sound absurd but the logic is this you
can simulate a quantum computer on a
classical computer but it gets more and
more difficult to do so the more qubits
you have now iBM has got the current
record for simulating a quantum computer
with 56 qubits
so people are seeing this is the target
that if you build a quantum computer
with more than 56 qubits you can't
simulate that with a classical computer
and so the kuan computer can do
something better than what a classical
computer can do so the problem that
they're looking at showing that the
quantum computer can beat a classical
computer at is a certain problem called
a sampling problem now if you remember
back when I was talking about a qubit
being in a superposition state between 0
& 1 that gives you the probability of
which one you'll get back imagine if
you've got 50 cubits and they're all
entangled together they simultaneously
in about a quadrillion States that's a
million billion States at the same time
but when you measure that computer it
just gives you back one state which will
just be a bit string of 0 0 1 0 1 1 1
corresponding to each qubit now if you
keep measuring it that computer over and
over and over again you'll get different
bit strings back so different States
back but over time you'll build up a
distribution of those states the more
likely ones and the less likely ones and
that's a probability distribution and
each time you measure the quantum
computer that's like taking one sample
from that probability distribution now
quantum computers do that completely
naturally whereas simulating that whole
thing on a classical computer is
incredibly difficult
so that's the problem that they're
looking at proving that a quantum
computer can do it better than a
classical computer so what's that
problem good for absolutely nothing to
begin with I mean there is some
crossover between this kind of sampling
problem and something probably get in
machine learning but the shapes of those
problems in quantum computing and
machine learning are very very different
but they come from the same sort of
underlying physics which is called
statistical mechanics so there's a
tentative overlap there which people at
Google are very very interested in but I
don't want to undersell this achievement
because if you think about it classical
computers have been around for 70 years
and they've had literally trillions of
dollars worth of money pumped into
research and development to reach them
to the incredibly sophisticated machines
they are now quantum computers have been
around for 20 years ish and have had say
a hundred million maybe a billion
dollars worth of investment for that
technology this new novel technology to
come along and beat the classical
computers in even one narrow thing is a
it's a huge achievement and that's only
gonna progress in the future I'm really
excited to see how that whole thing
unfolds and finally I just want to end
with the fact that I think's incredible
you know I said that you can simulate
using our best supercomputers you can
simulate a quantum computer with 56
qubits now if you raise the number of
qubits up to 260 the size of computer
you need to simulate that would need
more bits than there are atoms in the
entire known universe which i think is
just absolutely bonkers but I love it
thanks so much for watching that's all
I've got for you today and thanks also
to the sponsor of this video
brilliant org there are a website where
you learn by doing and I don't know
about you when I was at university I
would sit down I'd write down all the
lecture notes at the time where I'd
really learned the subject was when I
sat down and did
problems and brilliant do a great job of
making this fun and slightly addictive
they have a way of framing questions
that I get slightly obsessed with trying
to work out the answer to but that makes
it really fun and they cover a bunch of
different subjects physics mathematics
computer science and many more so if
you're interested in checking that out
go to brilliant org slash do s the links
also in the description below and
otherwise thank you for watching again
and I'll see you on the next video